I mean you teach people how to create
hard coherence and self-regulate and it
makes sense then with a coherent brain
that can hold the image of their future
they can actually then rehearse who
they're going to be they can bring up
the emotions of their future now here's
the cool part if they can feel their
gratitude before their healing their
Healing Begins if they feel their
abundance or their worthiness before
they have their wealth it will start
generating abundance if they start being
in love with themselves and being in
love with life they'll create an equal
That's the Law if they're in awe of life
or an awe of the moment they're going to
have a mystical experience if they're
empowered they're going to start
stepping towards their success so then
when we wait for the outer World to
Change our internal State that's a
conditioning process because some people
will live in lack and separation their
entire life because they're not creating
anything when this happens then I'll
feel happy that's the illusion of
three-dimensional reality that's cause
and effect but feeling the emotion ahead
of the experience is causing an effect
hey it's Evan Carmichael and I make
these videos because in my first
business I struggle to believe in myself
I quit on my best business partner and
the thing that saved me was watching the
successful stories of entrepreneurs they
gave me the inspiration to keep going as
well as the strategies of what to do and
quite honestly I still need their
stories and motivation today as well so
today let's live your best believe life
and learn how to visualize better
enjoy
so the heart when it's coherent tends to
produce
an external magnetic field that's up to
three meters wide now you've got a Wi-Fi
signal now when you have a coherent
brain the brain could actually lay the
information
on that signal and the thought of your
wealth or your health can be carried on
the frequency of that heart emotion
emotions are the end product of an
experience right
uh epigenetics says it's the environment
that signals the gene if the environment
signals the Gene and the end product of
an experience in the environment is an
emotion that person's signaling genes
ahead of the environment and now they're
biologically
believing behaving and actually becoming
that person so if the person sustains
that Satan State and we look at novice
meditators that come for a week and
ninety percent of them and and the
metabolites not just a few the majority
of the metabolites and novice meditators
suggest that their bodies in a different
life we keep using this term heart
coherence I know there's a part of my
audience going okay what is that my
understanding of hard coherence
essentially physically means that your
breathing and heart are actually in
unison at one point and that you sustain
that over a duration of time elaborate
on that and go for it coherence is
rhythm it's a Cadence and when you're in
fear or you're in survival and your
heart rate increases in your respiratory
rate increases your brain waves go up
into this aroused state right and people
spend 70 percent of their life
anticipating the worst case scenario
that's going to happen in their life and
prepare for the worst chronic stress
does what
it causes us to hold our breath all
right so we found you know in our
research and
working with the heart math Institute
and also some of the stuff we've been
doing that if you slow your breathing
down you slow your brain waves down and
if you teach your body to move out of
survival there's only one other thing it
wants to do it wants to create right so
now just imagine a big drum
and now you're so contracted that you
can't you can't hit that drum and as you
learn and teach a person how to convert
from that fight or flight nervous system
to the nervous system of relaxation
the heart actually starts to bloom and
when you place your attention on your
heart we have the data I can say this
emphatically
and when that heart starts to beat in
Rhythm it starts to inform the brain
that it's time to create like taking a
big sheet and going like this a wave of
energy goes right to the brain the brain
goes right in the alpha and says it's
safe now to create examine other
possibilities you're out of survival
right so then as you hit that drum
repeatedly there's a wave of sound
that's produced and the more coherent it
is the more it can carry information
right
or if you drop a pebble in the water and
you drop another Pebble in the water and
drop another Pebble in the water when
your heart is coherent there's a
magnetic field rule number two is be
conscious of your unconscious self do
you have your own spiritual practice
that you personally do and how has that
changed over the years and how has that
helped you and that sort of thing so I'm
trying to let people get a feeling of
different things people do and how it
can help them
well for me personally uh when I wake up
in the morning I ask myself the same
exact question every single day
and that question is
what is the greatest ideal of myself
that I can be today
now there's enough science to support
this concept that when we begin to
become conscious of our unconscious
thoughts we begin to notice our
unconscious habits and behaviors and we
begin to pay attention to our emotions
the fact that we are observing those
aspects of the old self means that we're
no longer the old self or begin to
become Consciousness observing the old
self
so my process is to become conscious of
who I no longer want to be
and if 95 percent of Who We Are by the
time we're 35 years old is a set of
memorized behaviors attitudes beliefs
perception perceptions and emotional
reactions that function like a
subconscious computer program then it's
entirely possible that we're unconscious
most of our waking day right so then the
hardest part about change is not making
the same choices we did the day before
so the biological model of change
requires unlearning and relearning it
requires breaking the habit of the old
self and Reinventing a new self what we
say in Neuroscience pruning synaptic
connections and sprouting new
connections unmemorizing emotions that
are stored in the body
and then reconditioning the body to a
new mind into a new emotion it's
literally drawing your energy from the
past and putting it into the future
deprogramming and reprogramming you know
breaking the habit of the old self is
really the model so when I sit down in
my discipline and my morning uh
meditation the first thing that we have
to do is we have to become conscious of
our unconscious self so it's entirely
possible that we're judging other people
and we don't know that we're doing it
because it's an unconscious program it's
entirely possible that we're living by
guilt every single day because it's
become so common and so familiar to us
so as we begin to become conscious of
those unconscious States we're going
into the operating system of the
subconscious and making them conscious
so the more we are conscious of those
unconscious States the more control we
have on those later on in our day and so
most people
they start out with really good
intentions to think positively but they
have may been thinking acting or feeling
negatively for the last 25 years so I
just take a little bit of time and I
become aware of who I no longer want to
be
then I began to think about who I want
to be when I open my eyes what thoughts
I do want to fire and wire in my brain
what behaviors I do want to demonstrate
and if you begin to contemplate or even
mentally plan or rehearse your behaviors
if you do it properly mental rehearsal
shows that you begin to install the
neurological circuits in your brain so
now the brain looks like the experience
has already happened or better yet
the brain is primed now for you to get
your behaviors to match your intentions
in your waking day
if I can bring up the emotion of how
this new ideal would feel
the end product of every experience is
called an emotion so if I can begin to
feel what it would be like to be the
greatest ideal of myself
then I'm giving my body a taste of the
future emotionally
and the research shows that rehearsal
both changes the brain as well as the
body
so then if I can get my brain Prime to
be thinking differently
and I can get my body primed to be
feeling differently how you think and
how you feel creates a state of being
and the quantum field responds to who
we're being so our job then is when we
get up from our meditation we should
feel differently than when we sat down
but that's not enough then you have to
maintain your modified State of Mind and
Body your entire day and if you do that
properly and be greater than the
conditions in your environment
to be greater than the emotional
addictions and habits of the body and be
able to sustain that change for just a
suspended period of time
get ready because something unusual is
going to happen in your life that's the
law and it always come in a way that we
least expect because if we can expect it
it's nothing new it has to rock our
world it has to catch us off guard
and when we see the effects of our
change in our internal State being
produced in our external World we'll pay
attention to what we did and we'll do it
again
so for me personally I asked that
question what's the greatest ideal of
myself and I don't get up from my
meditation until I feel like that person
and then when I get in that state of
being then I do my best to live from
that state of being and how long does
that take it's a great question
well she takes some of us all day we
might never get up well it's really
great question because that's really
what people are afraid of I mean for me
personally
I allow for two hours every morning now
people say oh my God two hours do you
take two hours no but I allow for two
hours why because if I allow for one
hour my ego will say well there's not
enough time you won't get it done but if
I allow for two hours I'm not thinking
about time
so some days I'm able to find The Sweet
Spot of the present moment and in a
matter of moments I can become conscious
of my unconscious self and then decide
who I want to be and bring up the
thoughts and emotions and I can change
my state of being
other days I'm thinking about flights I
have to catch people I have to see
emails I have to check
you know staff members I have to meet
with and I'm not in the present moment
so it may take me some days
45 minutes to an hour just to keep
bringing my body back to the present
moment but that's the work
and I always know that if I keep going
and I keep working with bringing the
body back to the present either from the
future from the past if I do that
properly
I always say the same thing when I
connect I always say that was so worth
it it was so worth making the effort to
to get Beyond Myself
so I allow for two hours and doesn't
normally take me two hours but if I
allow for two hours then I can relax and
not have to think about time rule number
three is get intentional sometimes I
think people get confused with what
intention really is okay
so here's my definition of intention
getting clear on what you want that's it
so now sounds really easy like to get
clear on what you want the problem is is
that when the analytical mind gets
overdriven by the hormones of stress
we start thinking I want this but then I
need it on this condition so I can't
affect this person and I don't want to
lose that and if this occurs then this
is going to occur for this and this is
that's not intention that's trying to
control everything in your life well
what you're trying to do is say I want
this specific thing but I'm not willing
to lose any of these things or affect
any of these people it's got to land
right here the universe doesn't work
like that
intention as you may say
I want a healing I want a new job
I want a new relationship now the moment
you ask the question the what if
question what would it be like to be in
love what would it be like to have a new
job what would it be like to be in a new
relationship to do whatever to be healed
the moment you ask that question
uh the part of your brain called the
frontal lobe which is the crowning
achievement of the human being 40 of
your brain is the frontal lobe it's the
workshop it's the creative Center
frontal lobe has connections to all
other parts of your brain
the moment you ask an open-ended
question you speculate a possibility
a creative Center turns on and it looks
out over the landscape of the entire
brain and begins to call up different
networks of neurons that are stored in
your brain based on something you've
learned intellectually knowledge or
something you've experienced in your
life like while I know what it is to be
in love or I know what it is to have a
good job or I read a book about it
and it begins to call up these different
networks of neurons and then it
seamlessly pieces them together to
create a new idea a new vision
and when you put all those networks
together and they fire and tandem you'll
get a clear picture in your mind and
that clear picture is called intention
now
the more you have conditions or the more
you have specifics about that job like
for example I want to make this amount
of money more a year I want to have
health benefits I want to have three
weeks vacation I want to travel I want
to work with great and unlimited
creative people that all is the elements
that help to add to that Vision now the
picture you get in your mind
could be could be the letter j the word
job or it could be just an image that's
personal to you but the image then
represents all of those conditions so
you can have several conditions that
make up your intention
but the intention typically is a symbol
like you may see a retreat center that
you may want to start and you have a
picture of it but once you see that
picture the next thing that happens you
start to live that dream
the moment you start to take that dream
and it turns into a living motion
picture
now you're in that imaginary place and
what happens is the moment it starts
taking on form and it starts taking on
time you start to experience and all the
things you're going to do
you're actually living in that future
and your brain does not know the
difference between the actual event that
takes place in your life and what you're
imagining in your mind we call it mental
rehearsal in my work but you're
literally rewiring yourself to the
Future now your brain is no longer a
record of the past
to now in fact they map to the Future
now most people stop at this level but
there's another level because once you
have that intention and I watched you do
this what makes the intention
have life is when you combine it with
that emotion
why because your body is your
unconscious mind it doesn't know the
difference between an experience in your
life that creates an emotion and an
emotion that you're fabricating by
thought alone so your body now as the
unconscious mind is living in that
future in the present moment and you're
beginning to epigenetically change your
cells in preparation for that event so
then here's the here's the condition the
caveat
that means then you can't wait for your
healing to feel wholeness you have to
feel homeless for your going to occur
that means you can't wait for your new
relationship to feel loved you have to
feel love so your relationship finds you
it means you can't wait to be to have
your new job to feel empowered you have
to be empowered by the fun of your new
job
so we're switching the model around
because most people wait for something
outside of them right to change how they
feel inside of them and when they feel
better inside of them they get relief
and they say I like you you help me with
that that's cause and effect that's the
old model of reality what we're talking
about here in the quantum model is
causing an effect which means then you
are going to have to change how you
think and how you feel before the
experience occurs in order for the event
to find you
so if someone is looking for love
they're not instead of looking outside
they're going to think about who and
what they want in a person that they can
fall in love with exactly that's
attention right okay so those are the
waves that they're putting out that's
the information that they're putting out
now that information has to have a
carrier which is they better feel love I
mean if you're going to enter in a
relationship with me and you want to be
in love but you're not bringing any love
to the relationship why would I want to
love you right you'd have to bring that
so like if your personality creates your
personal reality
and your personality is made with how
you think how you act and how you feel
the present personality who's listening
to this show has created the present
personal reality called their life
so if they wanted to create a new
personal reality a new life they would
have to start thinking about what they
were thinking about and change it
starting to become conscious of their
unconscious habits and behaviors and
modify them now here's the key
they have to look at the emotions that
they've memorized that keep them
anchored to the past and decide if those
emotions belong in their future so most
people try to create a new personal
reality as the same personality and it
doesn't work in other words a wealthy
person doesn't feel lack you can't bring
lack into your future
you know a sick person doesn't feel
desperation they feel homeless
and so then
by re-identifying with the future and
then instead of your past present
reality is very very easy conversation
to have
but actually doing it requires a
tremendous amount of awareness
and that awareness means then that you
have to stay conscious and pay attention
to who you're being all the time and you
can't let any thought slip by your
awareness that's going to cause you to
return back to the old self you can't
begin to react emotionally to people and
things in your life that cause you to
feel like the old self you can't talk
and complain and blame and make excuses
or go back to old habits and expect your
future to show up you have to maintain
that state for a period of time so that
your body catches up
because the body and brain live in the
past so it takes a certain amount of
repetition and a certain amount of
Consciousness a certain amount of will
finally arrive there and I'm happy to
say that it's possible also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is be the
shepherd of your thoughts 95 to 99
percent are created from lifestyle you
can take two identical twins
same exact gene expression same exact
genome one dies at 55 the other one dies
at 81. why they're in a different
environment or their perception of the
environment so now it's not that the
gene is a parts list of possibilities
right so now
here's the point
if a person is perceiving the
environment or or in an environment
where they're constantly living in fear
or anxiety or anger or aggression or
frustration
then it makes sense then that those
emotions would influence certain
thoughts and certain thoughts would make
certain feelings or certain emotions
well if you're living by the same
emotions every single day
the it's it's the environment that
signals the gene the end product of an
experience in the environment is an
emotion
so your body is objective if you're
living in fear whether there's any
fearful conditions in your environment
your body's believing it's an
environment where it needs to feel fear
so then the person then keeps signaling
the same gene because they're feeling
the same emotion they're responding to
the same environmental condition they're
signaling the same gene you keep making
the same protein he keeps signaling the
same gene over time it's like taking a
copy of a copy of a copy of a copy all
of a sudden the body starts making it
cheaper protein the gene down regulates
and now the body's moving out of balance
so then
here's the question if you're thinking
the same thoughts making the same
choices demonstrating the same behaviors
creating the same experiences that
produce the same emotions and then those
same emotions influence your very same
thoughts than your biology your
neuroscircuitry your neurochemistry your
hormones and your gene expression is
going to be equal to how you think
how you act and how you feel and how you
think how you act and how you feel is
called your personality and your
personality creates your personal
reality that I love that I love that so
if you're going to change your life
change your personal reality
you gotta change your personality you
got to start changing your thoughts you
got to start thinking about what you've
been thinking about and say do I really
want to think this like you become The
Shepherd of your thoughts The Gardener
of your own mind you start to become
aware of your unconscious habits and
behaviors and say my goodness how am I
speaking how am I acting you start
looking at emotions that you live by
every day and say my goodness I didn't
even know it was guilt it just feels
like me and or lack and now the person's
becoming conscious of their unconscious
part of themselves and the more
conscious we become of the unconscious
self the less unconscious we go during
the day so it begs the question
new thoughts that lead to new choices
new choices that lead to new Behaviors
new behaviors create new experiences new
experiences produce new emotions new
emotions or the information coming from
the environment they signal new genes
and there's Evolution so now we up
regulate the gene you start making a
healthy protein the immune system starts
up regulating and all of a sudden it
makes new antibodies why because the
body's back in growth and repair and out
of survival rule number five is trust
the Unseen trusting in the Unseen oh
that's a big one that's a very big one
and a very important one already feeling
it and finding ourselves in this in a
place where we already are embodying
embodying all those qualities embodying
feeling that reality and then the brain
start changing shifting and being able
to how does this work what's the dynamic
tell us again let's make it really
simple okay thoughts are the language of
the brain feelings are the language of
the body so the currency of thought is
what creates a certain level of mind the
currency of feeling then has everything
to do with experience okay so knowledge
is for the Mind experiences for the body
so your brain has networks of neurons
that are arranged in certain patterns
based on things you learn intellectually
and things you've experienced in your
life
so your forebrain is the Builder it's
the designer it's the CEO and when you
begin to speculate possibilities when
you start to think about
a better way to do something or
something you want to experience or
something you want to do or some future
event
it's an amazing phenomenon because their
researchers are beginning to show that
not only do we remember a past
but the brain actually can remember a
future and so how does it do that well
because the forebrain has connections to
all other parts of the brain it can take
a little bit of that knowledge
from a specific neural network and a
little bit of experience and another
neural network of knowledge and another
neural network of experience and it can
seamlessly piece it together
create a new level of mind and then your
brain gets a picture or an image and
then you transfix your mind on that
image and those neurons string into
place
that begin to Fire and wire together and
every time you remind yourself what you
want to experience you're reinforcing
the circuitry in your brain to begin to
install the hardware for you to actually
experience that future event in other
words the brain already looks like it's
already had the event now that's super
cool because it really says then that
we're remembering a future potential now
feelings and emotions are the end
product of past experiences and we can
remember experiences better because we
can remember how they feel so when
you're in the midst of an experience and
you're seeing and smelling and tasting
and feeling and hearing and you're
immersed in the environmental cues
there is a rush of information that
causes the brain to pattern into
specific neural networks and then
there's a very strong emotional quotient
that the brain releases to the body so
then if feelings and emotions are the
end product of past experiences then is
it possible then to tune into that
future potential
and put so much of our attention on
until it's real and the end product of
that experience in our own mind is an
emotion and we begin to feel how that
event would actually take place or feel
ahead of the actual experience now we're
no longer relying on the external World
to Change our internal chemistry and
then when we feel different we look to
see who or what caused it what we're
saying is now is that we're giving
thanks ahead of the actual experience or
we're falling in love to the point that
the body is as the unconscious mind is
getting the signal before the actual
environmental experience the body does
not know the difference between the
event and reality that produces the
emotion and the emotion you create by
yourself now here is the key
most people use their senses to Define
reality we all do but the quantum model
says we're going to use our mind to
Define reality and we're going to
convince our body emotionally that that
future event has already happened now
when your mind and body are working
together when your thoughts and feelings
are aligned you're in a state of being
and that state of being is what that
flow is all about now some people would
say oh that's nonsense or that's so
unrealistic well it is nonsense it's
beyond the census and it is unrealistic
because it isn't a reality yet but
you've already experienced it enough
times that you can surrender now and let
go because you already can trust that
somehow it's going to happen you don't
know how
or when and that should never be your
job because the moment you try to figure
out how or when you go back to that old
identity trying to control the outcome
but if you understand that the quantum
model says that there's an intelligence
that will organize the event in a way
that's right for you
and you've already experienced it enough
times until you feel it on a cellular
level
then you already ex you are in the state
of experiencing it in terms of being it
and then when you're in that state of
being that is a personality and your
state of being is your personality and
your personality creates a new personal
reality so here's the beauty behind it
you can let go now and and surrender to
some greater intelligence and and and be
tickled by the outcome because you can't
be tickled unless you know unless you
don't know when it's going to happen or
where it's going to happen but the
physiology of tickling says that you can
surrender and not know when or how and
you'll be tickled so the universe wants
to tickle us in a certain way and rule
number six the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is feel the
experience imagine how many things you
could get done if you had an infinite
amount of time
an infinite number of possibilities
that's the quantum now in the quantum
there's nothing structural there's
nothing material there's nothing
physical there's no form right so what
is it made of it's made of energy
frequency vibration
thought Consciousness information and
every thought in that realm has a
frequency so all possibilities already
exist you don't have to create the
possibility in fact all you have to do
is become aware that exists
the moment you do that you you're
changing the thought and you're
producing a different frequency now if
the person is astute enough to feel the
frequency of the thought in the quantum
and not wait for the experience to
happen but the thought of abundance
would produce the feeling of abundance
for most people in three-dimensional
reality the thought of abundance
produces the lack of not having it
that's why they're trying to create it
right but in the quantum you got to feel
it in order to experience it okay so as
you get closer and closer to that point
that source that Singularity pure love
the zero point field whatever you want
to call it a universal mind that the
Creator pure Consciousness as you get
closer and closer to it
the closer you get to it the more bliss
the more love the more the more
um ecstasy you feel uh then you're not
no longer creating from lack or
Separation The Closer you get to it in
the process of creation the shorter the
distance between the thought of what you
want and the experience of having it
between the cause and the effect from
one point of Consciousness then the
other point of Consciousness so then
people can create from the field instead
of from matter
if they have a coherent brain and a
coherent heart and they actually can
send the coherent signal out and feel
the emotion ahead of the experience then
those synchronicities and opportunities
that they're creating from fifth
dimensional reality requires doing less
somehow it's drawn to us or it comes to
us it comes in ways that we least expect
that surprises us like whoa where did
that come from and now what does that do
it proves to you that you're the creator
of your life that instead of the victim
of your life and what's a victim you say
to someone why are you feeling this way
what's wrong with you today and they say
I am this way
because of that person because of that
circumstance what they're really saying
is that person or circumstances actually
controlling my feelings and controlling
my thoughts well anything that's
controlling my feelings and my thoughts
I'm victim to right so yeah it makes
sense then that when things are good you
feel good when things are bad you feel
bad right so so when you start changing
the way you think and feeling it starts
producing outcomes in your life you're
going to believe you're more you're the
creator of your life and less of the
victim of your life and the hardest part
about all of this is just making the
time to do it ah well he just landed on
I have two things I want to ask in mind
but the first was why is it so damn hard
like why is it so hard to get to that
place where you can
whether it be believe that leads to
knowing like why what is what are those
big hurdles for people to get over and
you know one is making the time to do it
but then there's like being in it and
actually and it being hard like I
struggle with that sometimes you where
you really am to embody the the feeling
and to really like get yourself there
it's it feels like there's so many
blockages it's a difficult thing to
achieve yeah well I think it's it's so
much easier to forget this information
than to remember it I think it's I think
we're wired and I'm so wired uh to for
such limitation you know and and as I
said my belief about human potential has
changed so dramatically so the first
thing I think is so valuable
is this information in the right
information sure you know we do really
best our best to combine quantum physics
with Neuroscience with neural
Endocrinology with psychoneuroimmunology
mind-body connection epigenetics protein
metabolism cellular biology
electromagnetism why because if
knowledge is power knowledge about
yourself is self-empowerment so
every time you learn something new
you're forging Connections in your brain
but the research shows if you don't
repeat it you don't review it you don't
think about it they prune apart within
hours or even days so if learning is
making those connections and remembering
is maintaining and sustaining them okay
so if you can build a model of
understanding with people and nothing
has left the conjecture nothing is left
to Superstition nothing's left the dogma
and they can learn that information and
instead of getting on their cell phone
and scrolling through their social media
or looking at whatever watching TV or
getting distracted if they learn that
information and they have the
opportunity to teach it back to somebody
and they begin to share that information
in right in the event right and it's
like Retreats and the Retreats when you
when you give information to people
you're like okay now talk to talk about
it to each other and we stop and we
talked about it and and it's it become
if you don't understand the information
well enough you can't explain it yeah
it's not wired in your brain but if you
can't explain it you're installing the
neurological Hardware in your brain
right for what in preparation for the
experience so we've discovered the more
you understand what you're doing yeah
and why you're doing it
the better results of how it gets easier
and you assign meaning to the task and
when you assign meaning to a task
the prefrontal cortex turns on and says
that the brain shut up quiet down here
this is a moment where I want to really
execute really well and it silences all
the other circuits in the brain so you
can focus on a single-minded thought
everything is possible you know when you
believe that's
a kind of clicker you have to believe
but it's not that hard it's really
pretty easy
our belief
creates our entire life experience and
so you can't if I put it this way you
can't experience anything in life
that is outside of your own beliefs
so and that's that's the case for every
single one of us we really can't
experience anything that's outside of
our beliefs if we can't experience
anything that's outside of our beliefs
what that means is look at all those
hearts that's so beautiful
what that means is there's not really
one world we kind of think there's one
world but there isn't really because
we're all experiencing a world based on
our beliefs and not one of us has the
same beliefs not one of us so that means
there's a different world for every one
of us
so all of your beliefs
are held in your subconscious mind and
the subconscious mind is just a part of
your mind there's the conscious mind and
then there's the subconscious mind
there's an actual which is actually
higher than the conscious mind and so we
use our conscious mind with all of the
thoughts and everything that we have our
conscious mind is very present right and
so
to create anything
you are using your subconscious mind
your subconscious mind is what is really
what creates if I want to make it really
really simple then I would say in the
subconscious mind is what creates
it makes things appear and manifest
things and that's where all of your
beliefs are stored kind of neat huh
because you have to believe to manifest
something and your subconscious mind
creates everything so you can see it's
all kind of perfectly designed
so now to manifest you have to believe
and you have to believe that you already
have whatever it is that you want and
the reason that you have to believe you
have it already is because the
subconscious mind is only operating in
the present it can't reason it's just
like a program so if you say for example
um a new car is coming my new car is
coming I'm going to get a new car it's
coming well then it's always going to be
coming right that's the that's the thing
you have to imagine you have it now you
have to go off and you have to test
drive the car you've got to feel the car
smell the car and just then visualize
being in that car and then when you do
that that's how
if you do that enough that's how you'll
come to believe that you actually have
the car and the moment that you believe
there's manifestations instantaneous so
so the other ways to believe is to
affirm over and over and over
um so to be really repetitive for
example
um to visualize and visualizing is
incredibly powerful because when we
close our eyes and we put ourselves in
the picture and you must make sure
you're in the picture and you put
yourself in the picture with whatever it
is that you want and you close your eyes
and you just kind of create this mini
movie honestly
the subconscious mind does not know that
you're imagining it has no idea it just
sees that movie and recreates it it's
like a giant photocopying machine it
will just whatever you hold in your mind
it will
photocopy it warm into the world so
um so if you are thinking about
something in the future it's always
going to be in the future so you have to
imagine that you have it now you have to
act as if and for example if you wanted
to attract a perfect partner are you
acting as if your perfect partner's here
already and so there are just small
things that you can do that are super
super powerful for example are you
sleeping in the middle of your bed or
are you sleeping on one side of the bed
because your partner's on the other side
of the bed
do you have room in your wardrobe for
your perfect partner's clothes is there
room in your bathroom for their
toothbrush and for their things and so
you see they are just little things you
can set the table for two you don't have
to put food on the plate but just
setting the table for two is really
really powerful it's saying my perfect
partner's here already and the
subconscious mind will believe it and
your perfect partner will be attracted
to you through the most incredible
circumstances so
um if something hasn't manifested yet
and you really really want it and I I
doubt there's anybody out there who's
who wants something and it hasn't
manifested right I mean
um I'll tell you the reason why it
hasn't manifested is because you don't
believe you have it the voice within us
that believes that we are not allowed to
be happy
our card today is speaking to that
I believe I'm worthy of feeling good I
believe I am worthy of feeling good this
is often something that is a belief
system that sounds really nice but it's
actually far from our reality because
many of us have been brought up with the
belief system that we have to suffer to
succeed that we have to feel pain to
have purpose that we have to have
struggles in order to feel a sense of
Serenity in our life that is all quite
backwards it's when we feel good that we
actually attract more of what we want
into our life but we have to undo the
belief system that says who am I to feel
good who am I to feel great who am I to
be happy that belief system is an
ingrained belief system that can be
cultural that can be something that we
learned from our upbringing it can be
something that we have picked up from
this difficult experience that we're
going through right now with covid when
we witness people suffering we think
well how dare I be happy I would say to
you how dare you not be happy it's your
happiness it's the collective happiness
it's the group Collective happiness that
raises the energetic frequency of the
world if we those of us who have moments
of happiness and Grace and joy and
success and we don't celebrate them we
are doing the world a disservice we are
shutting down the light we are bringing
down the vibration so we we have to when
we feel good we have to reach for more
when we feel good we have to recognize
that that good feeling emotion has
momentum it has power it elevates our
children it elevates our family member
it elevates our friends it elevates
strangers on the street it is your
Divine Duty here on Earth to bring forth
that greatness that goodness that light
so when you hear that voice that says to
you you are not worthy of feeling good I
want you to hear my voice come through
and say to you who are you not to feel
good
this is your Divine Purpose it is your
mission and it is the way that you heal
and serve you got me we are more
comfortable being uncomfortable than we
are being happy
so when things are good and when we
start to get a sense of feeling good
our ego the voice of fear within us
starts to say hell no too good to be
true and it will find these weird little
Corners to pick up problems
we have a fault-finding mindset rather
than a solution happiness oriented
mindset so when that happens the next
time you notice that you're feeling good
and all is well and all of a sudden
you're like but I wasn't nice enough to
that person or my co-workers aren't in a
good place or I didn't do that right I
want you to speak back to that voice I
want you to say thank you for sharing
but I choose happiness instead
thank you for sharing but I don't
believe that voice anymore thank you for
sharing but I'm choosing this moment
give yourself permission in the moment
to speak back to the fault-finding voice
and start to claim the greatness of who
you are that is a pattern because you've
lived your life in a habitual pattern of
seeking problems and finding fault now
we have to redirect and create a new
habit and pattern of grounding you in
the truth of who you are which is
happiness joy peace and Grace sharing
that happiness joy and peace with so
much grace
that's what you're here for see this
line
that's called The Terror barrier yeah
jumping at you isn't it and on the other
side of the terror barrier is something
we call Freedom
and you know
very few people get through that Terror
barrier it's rather sad freedom is
available to everyone there isn't anyone
that cannot live the way they want to
live
see
why don't they
they don't know and they don't even know
they don't know
now I'm going to show you why people
experience buyer's remorse when they buy
something they really want and then they
back away
where they go to move and they don't
they go to change jobs and they don't
they go to move to another city and they
don't why
fear causes them to stay where they are
there's the individual the X represents
the unknown
Factor the paradigm
now there's a power flowing into this
individual's mind and they can make
anything out of it they want remember we
said we had the ability to choose
what do they choose they choose thoughts
that are in harmony with the Paradigm
now here's an important point the
Paradigm controls the vibration of this
thing we call our body our body is a
molecular instrument that's really what
it is it's a mass of molecules and a
very high speed of vibration
the vibration that the body's in on a
conscious level we call feeling
when a person says they feel this way or
they feel that way what they're really
doing is describing the vibration
they're in
now
they choose thoughts that harmonize with
the vibration they're in so they feel
comfortable they may not like the
results but they're comfortable
now let's move ahead let's take a look
here those people are getting x-tape
results and they don't like it
do you know what the problem with them
they're in bondage these people are
locked up
you know
Paradigm is like keeping a person in a
prison
only there's no locks on the door they
can open the prison and walk out into
Freedom anytime they want and they don't
they keep getting the same results over
and over and over again they're in
bondage
now let's go ahead here's the same
person
X-Type conditioning X-Type vibration the
power is flowing into them
and for some strange reason from Left
Field above boom in comes a y-type idea
what is the y-type idea the y-type idea
represents anything that you might want
to do that you're not doing
yet might be moved to another city
change jobs sell the house buy the farm
whatever it may be
ask the little girl for the date ask the
guy to go to lunch
go make the sale
buy what you want
go where you want to go that's the why
idea but as long as the why ideas just
in the conscious mind it's just going to
be an intellectual exercise it's never
going to happen
so how do we make it happen well that's
when
everything goes haywire here we are here
same person okay the power Flows In
and what do they do they got the y-type
idea now for some for some strange
reason they know that they've got to get
emotionally involved that they're going
to act on that idea they don't
understand what's going to happen but
clearly understand this your central
nervous system is the most complex
electrical system in the universe
the central nervous system
is mind-boggling yet would make the
electrical system in a supercomputer
look like a toy now the second you take
the idea from your intellect and impress
it upon the subject of mine that's when
all hell breaks loose because the body
moves in to an extra XY vibration it's
not in the X vibration not the one that
we're comfortable with may not like the
results but we're comfortable no on a
conscious level everything's going crazy
on a conscious level we experience doubt
the doubt turns into an emotion called
fear and that fear is expressed through
the body as anxiety
see that person is getting emotionally
involved to move ahead do you know what
happens they hit that Terror barrier and
they bounce off it and right back into
bondage
and they're so relieved to get back
there
they're back where they're comfortable
they've canceled the sale
they've decided not to move
they're going to stay in the job that
they don't like at least they're
comfortable
now that's not a very good way to live
and you know something that's something
everybody experiences if they're going
to grow you're going to hit that Terror
barrier
see the terror barrier is going Beyond
where you're at going to a new level I'm
going to tell you something when I set a
goal
if if it doesn't scare and excite me at
the same time I know I'm going in the
wrong direction
now I also understand that my Paradigm
is going to try and get me to bounce
back to where I was it doesn't want me
to move ahead
I don't want to live there
ice lived there for the first 26 years
of my life and for the last 50 I've had
a phenomenal life and it just keeps
getting better and I want you to do the
same thing understand what I've just
said I'm going to back this up
they got emotionally involved in the Y
idea that moved their body into a
different vibration on a conscious level
they're experiencing some crazy stuff
they start to doubt their ability and
they'll never be able to pay for it they
experience fear the fear expresses
itself as anxiety
and bang you bounce off that Terror
barrier and you're right back
oh I might not be earning much here but
I know what it is
I I would love to move there but I'm
comfortable here I think I'll just stay
here these people are acting like they
have a contract to live forever and they
don't you know what to do say I'm going
to get rid of all that I understand it's
there but I don't want any part of it
and I'm going to go crashing right
through that Terror barrier
now does that get rid of the X energy no
the X energy
is still there you see but at least
you're over into Freedom you made the
move you did it and if you continue to
feed the right information into your
mind keep feeding that y idea keep
getting emotionally involved in the Y
idea you're there you're on the road
keep doing that you're going to find
that the Paradigm is going to change and
it'll just all go away
and you know where you're living
in Freedom you're living where you want
to live
buyer's remorse
is when you cancel the sale
buyer's remorse is when you stop just
before you buy what you really want
before you go for the thing that's going
to change your life and you know it
it's not moving to the other city it's
not starting the business of your dreams
it's not stepping out and betting on
yourself
that's a terror barrier that's causing
that
and if you don't learn to go through the
terror barrier I'm going to tell you
something you're going to stay right
where you are
for the rest of your days
that's not a good place to be
what did Joseph Campbell say
so true
they cave you fear to enter holds the
treasure you seek here's the hard truth
about getting great
it takes time and dedication it takes a
willingness to accept that you're not
yet good enough it takes the ability to
stare at the places that you know that
you're weak to really look at those
things and not let it affect your sense
of self-esteem and not let it affect
your sense of self-worth so that you can
still get the momentum going but you
have to understand that in the beginning
we're all terrible
and as Henry Cartier brassonne said your
first 10 000 photographs are your worst
and so the thing that really makes great
art are the people that continue to push
and the people that continue to work and
face how inadequate they are and really
understand that at the end of the day
greatness is a craft greatness is a
process greatness is a habit greatness
is the little things that you do every
day over time going out every day
unafraid of whether or not this is one
of the ten thousand terrible things that
you're gonna do it's being unafraid to
make those mistakes is being unafraid
that you're not yet great
and is Marianne radmaker said courage
doesn't always Roar sometimes courage is
the quiet voice at the end of the day
saying I will try again tomorrow
and that's it if you want to be great
that's what you have to do you've got to
get up again tomorrow you've got to be
willing to face another day you've got
to be willing to accept that you've got
to get through the bad ideas before you
can get to the good you've got to
understand that you have to start as an
apprentice you have to start as a person
going and getting tea and you have to
accept that that's the job that you
should be playing that you should be
working for somebody else you should be
looking up to somebody else and seeing
what they can teach you because what you
know
is that you're there to learn what you
know is that you're there to get through
the 10
000 bad photographs that you need to get
through to ultimately achieve greatness
and if you make the catastrophic error
that's so many make
to try to tell the world that you're
extraordinary today to try to get the
world to follow you and look up to you
and think that you're something today
because the people that really win are
the ones that invest today the ones that
listen today the ones that spend every
ounce of their energy amassing Mastery
getting better every day working their
asses off to improve their skill set to
relentlessly look at the things that
they're not doing well to understand
that they have to break themselves down
and get rid of all of their ego before
they can really find greatness
those are the people that we remember
so if you want to be remembered if you
want to achieve real greatness
you just need to have the courage to
show up every day
and take another swing take another
photo try another task do something that
scares you and do those little things
over and over and over until you win
just give yourself permission
to want the things that you want and
unless you believe that you're worthy
unless that you practice love you're
never going to think that you deserve
the things that you want right so tell
the story
okay so I'm probably gonna I mean
I'll shorten it so the bottom line is
that so in
1990 I was a senior in college at
Dartmouth and my parents came to visit
from Western Michigan and we went to
this place called Simon Pierce which is
a famous glass blowing Mill and as we
walked into the restaurant I had an
experience
that you may be able to relate to and
that is I walked in and I immediately
saw this painting hanging on the wall
and it was about the size of a door only
horizontal and it was a Vermont
landscape and I was drawn into it
immediately like I was no longer in that
restaurant I was standing in that field
I could feel that breeze I'd never ever
had an experience like that with a
painting have you ever had an experience
like that with art no I mean not like
that not like that I mean yeah my sense
was that this is very atypical for you
very
so I
kind of lost it the the the restaurant
was quiet and then
I leaned back and suddenly kind of back
in the moment I'm like I'm gonna own
this painting someday it just that was
what was right there and I looked at the
price and said like three thousand
dollars I'm like not today and I went
back and I sat down and that was it but
the painting never left my mind you see
there's something called The zygon Arc
effect I always say it wrong but it's
like there's a checklist in your brain
that when you have a moment where you're
like this is important your brain puts
it on a checklist yeah it's like a notch
yes a notch happens and now your brain
as part of the filter in the brain is
always going to be kind of scanning the
subconscious to let anything into your
mind related to that incident it can be
positive by the way like with the
painting or this is how trauma happens
too like you have this high intensity
emotional experience that notches
something in your brain and now your
brain kicks in to remember
so uh bottom line is uh I always thought
about that painting
years go by
whenever somebody would say Vermont I'd
think of the painting
I don't know why I can't explain it
never wanted a painting before was not
an art student it's going to last like
you're out collecting Arts no no and so
I you know fast forward the story 10
years and my uh Chris and I are engaged
and we're going to go up to Vermont to
see the leaves and immediately I'm like
we got to go to Simon Pierce I got to
show you the painting so we pull up to
the mill and we walk in and right in
front there is Boom a painting by the
same artist Gail Shepard and I'm like oh
my God it's here and we race all around
the place
and it's gone
and the funny thing was and this is the
way your brain works Chris was more
disappointed than I was
I literally turned to him and said it's
okay dude like it'd be weird if we're
still here after 10 years I'm gonna
track this thing down I actually said to
him you know what's gonna happen Chris
I'm gonna be able to buy this like 40
years from now it's going to be hanging
in the corporate Lobby of some building
and I'm gonna have to track down the
owner and pay like quadruple the money
they pay but I'm gonna own this thing my
mission yes so a couple years pass and
um it's my birthday I think I was
turning 30 and Chris says uh Chris gets
a couple people too
give money and he said I could buy
anything I wanted with it so I had what
500 bucks now I'm pregnant at the time
with our first kid
I should have bought a crib or stools
but for whatever reason the zeigon arc
effect takes over and I'm like the
painting so I call the mill and I get
this guy on the phone I'm like uh you
know I want to buy a kale Shepherd piece
and I said could you send me Polaroids
and he's like sure and I tell them the
budget and he goes I'll send you
Polaroids of some of her smaller things
and she's like blowing up in the
meantime right yeah she's a very very
successful Vermont landscape artist and
so I
I I say to him you know by the way
there's this one painting
and I describe the painting I'd seen
over 10 years ago and he said well that
was way before my time but I bet Gail
know
and I'm like Gail you know Gail he's
like of course I know Gail she like
lives in in down the road
here's her number
so for two days I paced around the
apartment with 500 bucks in my pocket
driving Chris crazy because I felt like
what am I going to say to her and I must
be a weirdo I've been stalking this lady
I've been thinking about her for 10
years I can't afford a painting you know
what who am I to buy a painting like
what the hell
so finally Chris is like would you call
her I'm gonna call her you're driving me
crazy so I call her and I start talking
a mile a minute and she was amazing
and then
um I said by the way there was this one
painting and I go and I explain this
painting there's a stand of poplar trees
down the center and a big mountainscape
behind it and this beautiful blue
Vermont sky and geese flying information
overhead and
I could hear her thinking on the other
end of the line
and she said you know Mel I've done so
many large-scale
uh paintings over the years I'd hate to
mistake the one you're talking about but
I'll tell you what
if my husband and I meet you and Chris
at the Mill at Simon Pierce and we'll
walk all around and have lunch and I'll
tell you the stories behind every
painting and if you don't see what you
like there I'll take you back to my
studio which is a couple miles down the
river and you can look at everything I'm
working on and if you don't see anything
you like there then you can go through
all my slides and see if you can find
that painting that you saw 10 years ago
and I said deal
so a month passes we go up to the mill I
walk in we meet each other she's amazing
she's like twice our age just incredibly
cool lady she's walking around as we're
walking around looking at these
paintings Rich I've got I'm like eight
months pregnant I'm realizing
these are 10 times the amount of money
that I have
I can't afford this
like I don't I don't have this kind of
money
and I'm getting like more and more into
that imposter syndrome what am I doing
mode oh my God I'm so embarrassed I'm
meeting somebody I idolize I don't
deserve to be here right wasting her
time because she thinks she's going to
get a Payday out of this correct we sit
down
and she goes now that you're sitting
down I have something to tell you
um
she said there's only been two times in
my career as an artist
that I've done two studies of the same
peace
and your painting is one of them
it's one of a pair
she knew all along she knew all along
she was playing games with you about not
knowing which painting yeah and she said
the sister piece to the one that you saw
all those years ago is sitting in my
studio right now where it's been for the
past 11 years
I start sobbing everybody's like totally
emotional her husband's like you should
have seen her when you when she was on
the phone with you it was like she saw a
ghost so we get in the car
and we drive to the mill
and when we walk in there in the center
of this massive kind of Barn Studio
space is an easel with a painting taped
up with painters tape on it and it was
the sister to my painting there were
slight differences not as much movement
in the grass but it was
one of the most extraordinary
experiences of my life it was as if time
suspended and I was
standing before that painting
in 1990
saying it would be mine
and there I was 11 years later
standing in front of it
and then I realized oh my God I can't
afford this
and Chris walks over and he's like
what's wrong and I'm like just promise
me someday like promise me that I don't
need a jewelry I don't need a car like
just promise me you will buy me this
thing
and he kind of leans over and goes hey
Gail how much for the big one and she
said um
Mel can have it for 500 bucks because
clearly when I was making it 11 years
ago I was making it for her
yeah
and so it hangs in my kitchen
it's on the back of the book
um this is the galley though right so
wait is it in the is it I think so yeah
yeah and
um it's a reminder every day that your
mind is designed to help you get what
you want
I never stop believing
that I could make it happen
and when you tell your mind what's
important to you
there is extraordinary science
that proves that your mind has a live
and ever-changing filter a live Network
that changes how it views the world What
it lets in what it blocks out and if you
program your mind correctly
and if you're clear about what you want
to create your mind will help you get
what you want you speak about the
neurophysiology of forgiveness
sure
think about
Frozen circuits
Frozen circuits are hardwired circuits
the more profound the insult
to the person
that is connected to a strong emotion
the more the brain freezes circuitry
the more we think about the experience
the more we fire and wire the circuits
in our brain yes or no
and the more we remember the event the
more we produce the emotions that are
associated with it and we're
conditioning the brain and body further
into the past yes or no yes yes and that
you keep doing it enough times it's no
longer conscious that you're holding a
grudge
it's no longer conscious that you're
stuck
it's now you're seeing everybody through
the lens of that experience and
everybody's a betrayer everybody can't
be trusted everybody is that same person
you're you're overlaying
the memory of re of your experience into
reality you're not seeing it the way it
is you're seeing that person wearing the
mask of the last person
that's the lens that we're perceiving
reality are you with me still
and so then anything in your life that
becomes remotely close to it based on
your limited perception triggers the
emotion in the network and you're back
in your past and you're acting like you
were when it happened are you with me
still
and so then the person says I'm not that
person and you say oh no I know I just
had this event in my past and I'm sorry
and then it's excusable but then here it
happens again
and there's nothing wrong with this
we all do it it's just how do we
overcome it
so then
you're sitting and doing the work
and you're you're moving energy up those
centers you're releasing the life force
into your brain
you are blessing those centers and
taking a scoop and moving it all the way
up and releasing it all the way up into
the field you're opening the channel
you're unfolding is nobody no one no
thing no wear and no time and the
identity and the personality is gone
which energy is going to move Scott to
what's going to follow the path
you're opening your heart once it gets
to your heart it's going to make its way
all the way up and when you feel love
and compassion
when you feel true true kindness and
care it's hard to hold the grudge
are you with me still yes so then from a
quantum physics point of view
you have that person always in the back
of your mind right you have the event
and the memory rolling around back there
because the very thing that you don't
want to have happen you're already
preparing for emotionally
are you with me still yeah so then from
a Quantum perspective you are actually
as a creator of reality
holding yourself hostage because of that
person
and you are holding them hostage because
of that experience and you have an
energetic Bond that's connecting you to
them
and you're sharing the same energy
and so then you're using each other to
reaffirm whatever that energetic
agreement is
are you with me still
so then
when you forgive someone it's because
there's been a strong change in your
emotional state
because the emotion is what's keeping
you energetically bound to them or to
more than one person
and so then once you start lowering the
volume to that emotion and the body
starts liberating energy and you're
calling your energy back to you because
the lower the volume of the emotion the
less you're going to pay attention to
that person there comes a moment where
there's a snap there's a release the
energy is broken and once it's broken
now all of a sudden you free yourself
and you free them and this has happened
to me in my life that people show up 10
years later completely changed and so
humble and so asking for forgiveness
just because they had transformed and
and I let them go
so then
forgiveness
from a Quantum perspective in a
neurophysiological perspective is just
taking your attention off them
it's all it is and when you start
getting happy with yourself
and you start feeling those elevated
emotions because you're striving for
that you wouldn't trade this for The
Grudge you were holding because this
feels too good are you with me still now
once that heart opens up
and you start having energy in the
center and it's releasing 1300 to 1400
different chemicals that begin to
restore and regenerate the body the
bodies start getting a lift of energy
once it makes it's here now you're going
to see that track sending in energy to
the brain the heart acts as an amplifier
to boost the brain are you with me still
so then once the Energy starts making
its way into the brain once the heart
starts to open we've measured this with
our students they have oxytocin levels
rise
once you start feeling oxytocin and you
feel more love then you feel The Grudge
so then you think
why would I want to give this up for
that person
that's called forgiveness you don't have
to try to do it
it just is a side effect of your
personal transformation and oxytocin
then
when it's released rushes right into the
amygdala the survival center of the
brain and the research is outstanding
and the first thing it does is it fits
in the same receptor sites as fear and
it lowers the volume to fear and anxiety
it shuts the lights out for aggression
and anger and hostility and it cools the
circuits off for suffering and pain and
the only thing you can feel is a love
for life and that's when you're free now
the practice of forgiveness
matter to matter you can do it but it
takes a long time and a lot of work and
then you forgive and then you're like I
don't want to forgive him yet
halfway forgive them
and just never really authentic
forgiveness do you understand
and you know there was a woman that came
to our work
and
she was raped by four men
when she was a teenager
and it was abusive
and she had severe severe night terrors
severe
anxiety and panic attacks she had cyclic
mood problems she had been to every
single doctor every single healer every
single alternative practitioner nothing
changed it
came to our event in
in Tacoma Washington
and she hit that point where she became
everybody everyone everything everywhere
every time every place she became the
Oneness
and and that frequency had a message for
her and it said and she was an
incredible Bliss when this happened
I sent four Angels disguised as rapists
for this moment
and that was the end of her tariffs
that was the end of her night she
couldn't have a relationship she
couldn't she could not live with anybody
she was she was isolated
one moment the Divine stepped in
and gave her the signal that was
carrying a very specific message and she
got the download not just that
not just the thought
she got the energy move right through
her body and she saw the whole thing
and that moment
is what she was waiting for that's what
the soul was waiting for now she's
healed she's healthy she's happy and
she's on with a new life she's born
again my mother would love this she's
born again in the same life reborn in
the same way didn't pass to a birth
canal for it
she just was born again in the same life
she got a new lease in one instant that
energy was carrying a message and it
made its way all the way into the body
and the Bliss and the joy and the
Gratitude and the love that she felt
and the message that was carried would
made total sense to her
she's free one instant to me that's true
forgiveness
that's the Divine having its way with
you you need to create an environment of
Excellence Excellence most people's
environments are not excellent the
people around you the the videos that
you watch the things that are on your
wall the voices that are in your head
you have these moments that are bold
that are courageous that make you feel
Unstoppable and you can do anything and
then you fall back down because the
environment is the thing that's keeping
you small it takes a giant effort to
overcome your environment you definitely
can it's definitely possible tons of
people are doing it but it takes that
giant effort to say I don't want to stay
stuck here
most people stay stuck most people make
minimal minimal minimal improvements in
their life year over year
and if you don't want to stay where you
are right now fast forward to one year
from today you don't want to stay stuck
you want to be in a different place
could actually be physically moving but
a different place in terms of your
finances in terms of your purpose in
terms of how much you're giving and
caring and sharing and the life that you
want to build you want to be somewhere
totally different like today this is not
acceptable anymore I accept that this is
where I am right now but where I end up
is not going to be the same spot as
where I am right now right if that's
your commitment the biggest shift that
will help you get from where you are now
to where you want to be is creating that
environment of Excellence what's the
fastest way to learn a language what's
the fastest way to learn Japanese well
it's to go to Japan sure you can read
some books and and you can hire a tutor
and the more intense it becomes the more
you're actually living it the faster
you're going to pick it up
so if you want to develop the mindset of
the high achiever if you want to become
that person the people that you look up
to the the whoever of the world like I
want to be the next whoever perfect that
person the more you hang around with
them the more it's going to rub off on
you how they think because how they
think how they act how they behave how
they see the world is very different
than how you see it right now and how
the people around you definitely see the
world right now
so how do you do it how do you start to
become it well
I look at what I'm doing
and this was one of my biggest
challenges when I was getting started
and honestly still in like I think the
biggest problem in the world is a lack
of belief
I'm trying to solve the world's biggest
problem people don't believe in
themselves enough I don't you don't
Oprah doesn't people don't believe in
themselves enough for the next level so
how do you start to believe in yourself
more the thing that helped me the most
was to have these successful people
around me constantly
and so I want to share a few tactics
that I think can really help you that
has really helped me as being the shy
introverted kid who never wanted to be
in front of a camera and was making 300
bucks a month and quit on my business
partner and thought life was over right
to now hear and it's taken me 20 years
to get here so hopefully we can shorten
that path for you if you actually follow
some of the advice in this video
so step number one how do we create that
environment of Excellence
what you feed into your brain really
really really matters
so figure out how you love to learn for
me it's videos I like to see things I
need to be visual if that's you then you
need to have a way to have those videos
coming into your life every day it can
be part of your morning routine that's
why I make this channel part of your
morning routine subscribe to the channel
every morning every weekday we got a new
video out there for you to give you the
shot of espresso to help you but if it's
not my channel it's some other channel
one of my other channels
subscribe to the channels that make you
feel bold powerful Unstoppable give you
hope give you belief in yourself
and then watch that video every day or
listen to that podcast every day or read
that book every day the trick is it
can't be the same book or the the one
video because that one video on repeat
is gonna lose its Effectiveness right
you know what you watch a video it gets
you all fired up and then you watch it
again the next day and it's not as like
oh what happened I don't feel as good
and you watch it the next day and the
feeling's gone so you can't just read
the same book over and over watch the
same video over and over and over again
the key is to find a consistent source
so if you love this channel you love
this video I'm making other videos just
like this
that you can subscribe to if you'd like
an author go find their other books or
go find the people that Inspire them so
that you can read something every day if
you'd like a podcast go find other
podcasts like them so you have something
every day so you you are
manipulating what comes in your head
with intention now
with intention so you're not just
scrolling through things like I am going
to watch one of these videos every day
to slowly shift myself forward because
it'll happen if you love Elon Musk and
you watch Elon Musk every day what will
happen is slowly day by day you will
start to think like Elon Musk it will
happen he will pull you forward you will
start to see the big difference in how
he thinks versus how the people around
you think versus how you think right now
and he will give you more courage and
more boldness and more a sense of hope
and purpose that you can do it too
you'll start to think more like him so
be careful who you pick and maybe you
don't like Elon Musk maybe you like
Kanye West or Oprah Winfrey or whoever
but the more you're around that person
the more you will start to think like
them so you want to put that as part of
your daily routine that every day
because yesterday was a different day
you might have been fired up bold
motivated great but today's today is a
new day
the motivation you had yesterday is
nowhere near what it is right now when
you wake up
right you got the best day of all time
you wake up the next day and it's gone
so how do you keep the consistency the
routine
tell yourself I'm going to watch a video
even when I don't want to even when I
feel low energy even when right all the
excuses we come up with I'm going to
watch a video to get myself into the
state I need to get into because I want
to follow I want to follow my dreams I
don't want to be stuck here anymore
[Music]
tied to that is then subscribe to the
channels
that make you feel that way so do an
audit
of all of the channels you follow on
YouTube of all the people you follow on
Instagram anywhere you're spending time
on social
do an audit of who makes you actually
feel more bold
and who makes you just waste time
or who makes you feel bad about yourself
there's some people you probably follow
who when you look at their stuff it
actually makes you feel worse about
yourself unfollow those people
immediately right they don't care about
you so why are you caring about them
and then the people who make you feel
better
follow them subscribe to them so that
when you happen to be on the platform
when you happen to be throwing going
through YouTube or Instagram you see
them and it makes you remember why
you're doing what you do so the first
part of it is a habit we are designing
our routines around this and I'm going
to watch a video every day with my
heroes so that they pull me forward
right we're putting it into our calendar
the second part of it is I'm also going
to subscribe to channels and people that
inspire me so that when I happen to be
on the platforms I'm feeding myself with
things that inspire me and lift me up
instead of waste my time or put me down
okay so that habit that environment
really really matters the second part of
environment to create our environment of
Excellence right is the physical
environment so this office inspires me
this office this was all with intent the
people on the wall behind me we got
Steve Jobs apginini my parents
Howard Schultz Kanye West the trophies
uh you know the YouTube stuff the the
getting
my hands wrong here this side you know
the art the art that people drew my book
uh my neck brace from when I broke my
neck like all even the colors on the
wall all of this it inspires me this
inspires me
when I walk into this office I I want to
believe more in myself
I see Steve Jobs staring me down I see
my parents staring me down it's like a
reminder of what I want to do because I
wake up and I and I don't have you know
the the most energy I don't feel super
bold and like let's go take on the day
right I don't have that as soon as I
wake up
but we manufacture it through the habits
and routines but also the actual
physical environment and the beauty
about this is you only have to set it up
once you know I set this up once and
then I walk in and every day I'm being
hit with these messages and reminders of
the person that I want to be
so whether that's a mood board you put
up for yourself whether it's people that
inspire you you have to look at the
thing it inspires you to want to push a
little harder it inspires you to want to
believe in yourself and more it inspires
you to want to go off and take some kind
of action today the physical environment
matters a lot and you can control that
so think about think about your office
think about your bedroom think about
your car think about where you're
spending significant time and how much
of that has actually been done with
intent
how much of your physical environment
has been created with intent to make you
believe in yourself more
it matters a lot and then the third
thing really quick is the actual your
outfit the clothes that you wear how you
show up for yourself when I put this on
I remind myself that I'm a superhero
going to work that
fighting
I want people to believe in themselves
more and I'm going to work when I see
there was a green arrow show I used to
watch
and when they were in their their base
in their Lair they always put their
outfits on a mannequin right so they're
when they're out fighting crime they're
in their uniforms but then when they
come back to their base they they're in
normal clothes but they put their
outfits on a mannequin so I went and got
myself a mannequin it's it's just you
can't see it but it's just sitting here
off camera I got a mannequin and it's
got my hoodie on it as a reminder that
I'm a superhero going to work every day
and again that might sound really cheesy
or dumb or corny but I like it it works
for me and putting this on every day
instead of just showing up in my pajamas
I just I work from home
you know we've got 30 something people
on the team uh I I don't see my team
physically that often most people work
from home I could just show up every day
in my pajamas
by putting this on
reminds me that I'm a superhero with a
mission
God is up to you but but
you present yourself for yourself not
just for the camera I'm not putting this
on just for the camera I'm putting this
on because it's what I put on this is
for me
I could make a video in my pajamas
that's fine but I'm making this for me I
wear this for me what do you need to do
for you not just because there's some
expectations when your expectations of
yourself become higher than what you
think other people's expectations are
for you that's when the game starts to
change when I'm wearing something just
because of how I think you guys will
perceive me or or some speech I'm doing
or some meeting
I'm I'm only living up to that person's
standard to what I think their standards
are and said no I'm doing this for me I
wear this for me I show up like this
even if I'm not making any kind of
content I only make content once a week
usually for YouTube what are the what am
I doing the other days of the week I'm
still wearing this because I'm a
superhero going to work and it's my
reminder
this is how you start to create an
environment of Excellence guys your
environment is keeping you where you are
your environment is keeping you stuck
and if you don't want to be stuck
anymore if you want to change your
circumstances if you don't want to be in
the same spot you are right now one year
from today you have to create an
environment of Excellence
how do we do that number one we start
feeding our mind with Excellence from
the videos and podcasts and books from
people who Inspire Us number two we
change our physical environment so that
you walk into a room you walk into your
car you walk into your bedroom or office
or wherever you're spending time and it
pushes you forward to step into the
person that you want to be and then
number three The Outfits what you wear
how you present yourself having a higher
standard for yourself than what other
people expect that you are a superhero
going to work every day because you are
on a mission
you've got a great heart you've got tons
of ideas
I see it over and over and over and over
and over again
so much potential
and just stuck
just stuck
because there's a lack of momentum that
stems from having a really poor
environment
if you can just change with intention
that I am going to create an environment
of Excellence for myself that inspires
me and pushes me forward to step into
the person I want to believe that I can
be
you can do that every day
entire life will change everything we as
human beings have created
on this planet
but essentially fast created in our
minds
all that you see which is human work on
this planet
first
found expression in the mind then it got
manifested
in the outside world
[Music]
the wonderful things that we have done
on this planet
and the horrible things that we have
done on this planet both have come from
the human mind so if we are concerned as
to what we create in this world it's
extremely important that first of all we
learn to create the right things in our
mind how we keep our minds
if we do not have the power to keep our
minds the way we want it
what we create in the world is also
going to be very accidental and
haphazard
so learning to create our minds the way
we want is the basis of creating the
world the way we want
there is a wonderful story in the yogic
lore
on a certain day a man took a walk
he went for a long walk
accidentally unawares he walked into
Paradise fortunate isn't he
just took a walk and he landed up in
Paradise
it's long walk
he felt a little tired
so he thought oh I'm tired I wish I
could rest somewhere
he looked around there there was a nice
tree
underneath which there was very cushiony
grass
so it was inviting he went and put his
head down there and slept
after a few hours he woke up
well rested and he thought oh I'm well
rested
I'm feeling hungry I wish I had
something to eat
and he thought about all the nice things
that he ever wanted to eat in his life
and instantly all those things appeared
in front of him
you need to understand they have the
services like that
[Music]
ask questions
who came and he ate
stomach became full then he thought
oh my stomach is full I wish I had
something to drink
[Music]
all the nice things that he ever wanted
to drink he thought about it and all of
them just appeared it went drinking
people also don't ask questions so he
drank
now with a little bit of alcohol in him
you know Charles Darwin told you all of
your monkeys your tail fell away not me
Charles Darwin told you that you were
all monkeys and your tail fell away and
then you became human yes definitely the
tail fell away but the monkey
in yoga we always refer to an
unestablished mind
as murkata which means a monkey
why we are referring to the Mind as a
monkey is
what are the qualities of a monkey
one thing about a monkey is it's a
necessary moment
[Music]
and another thing about the monkey is if
I say you're monkeying somebody what
does it mean imitation
monkey and imitation have become
synonymous
so these two essential qualities of a
monkey are very much the qualities of an
unestablished mind unnecessary moment
you don't have to learn it from the
monkey you can teach it to the monkey
and imitation is full-time job of the
Mind
so when these two qualities are on a
mind is referred to as a monkey
so this monkey became active within him
he just looked around thought what the
hell is happening here
I asked for food food came
I asked for drink drink came
there must be ghosts around here
and ghosts came
oh the ghosts have come they are going
to surround me and torture me he thought
immediately the ghosts surrounded him
and started torturing him
then he started screaming in pain and
said oh they're going to kill me and he
died
just now he said he's a fortunate being
the problem is he was sitting under a
kalpa rickshaw or a wishing tree
he asked for food food came he asked for
drink drink came he asked for ghosts
ghost came he asked for torture torture
came he asked for death death happened
now don't go looking for these kalpa
rukshas in the forest you can barely
find a tree
these days
a well-established mind
a mind which is in a state of samyukti
is referred to as a cultivation
if you organize your mind
to a certain level of organization it in
turn organizes the whole system
your body your emotion your energies
everything gets organized in the
direction
once all these four dimensions of you
your physical body
your mind your emotion and the
fundamental life energies are organized
in One Direction once you are like this
anything that you wish happens without
even lifting a little finger actually
it would help to assist it with activity
but
even without doing any activity you can
still manifest what you want if you
organize these four dimensions
in One Direction and keep it unwavering
in that direction for a certain period
of time
right now the problem with your mind is
every moment it is changing its
direction
it is like you want to travel somewhere
and every two steps if you keep changing
your direction the question of you
reaching the destination is very remote
unless it happens by chance
so organizing our minds and in turn
organizing the whole system
and these four basic dimensions of who
you are right now in One Direction if
you do this you are a kalpa Brookshire
yourself
anything that you wish will happen
but right now if you look at your lives
everything that you have wished for till
now if it happens you're finished
everything and everybody that you have
desired for if all of that lands up in
your house today could you live with
that
once we're empowered like this it's very
important
that our physical action emotional
action mental action and energy actions
are controlled and properly directed
if it is not so we become destructive
self-destructive right now that is our
problem the technology which is supposed
to make our life beautiful and easy has
become the source of all the problem
that we are destroying the very basis of
our life which is the planet
so what should have been a boon we are
making a curse out of it
what has brought incredible
levels of comfort and convenience to us
in the last
100 years or so has also become a threat
to our life simply because we are not
conscious action we are in a compulsive
state of action
so organizing our minds fundamentally
means moving from a compulsive state of
activity to a conscious state of
activity
you might have heard of people
for whom they ask for something and
beyond all expectations it came true to
the true for them
generally this happens to people who are
in faith
now let's say you want to build a house
if you start thinking oh I want to build
a house to build a house I need 50 lakhs
but I have only 50 rupees in my pocket
not possible not possible not possible
the moment you say not possible you are
also saying I don't want it
so on one level you're creating a desire
that you want something on another level
you're saying I don't want it so in this
conflict it may not happen
someone who has some faith in a God or
in a temple or whatever
who is how simple-minded Faith Works
only for those people who are
simple-minded thinking people
too much thinking for them it never
works a childlike person
who has a simple faith in his God or his
Temple or whatever
he goes to the temple and says Shiva I
want a house I don't know how you must
make it for me
now in his mind there are no negative
thoughts will it happen will it not
happen is it possible is it not possible
these things are completely removed by
the simple Act of Faith
now he believes Shiva will do it for him
and it will happen
[Music]
so is Shiva going to come and build your
house no I want you to understand God
will not lift his little finger for you
what you refer to as God he's a source
of creation
as a Creator he has done a phenomenal
job there's no question about it could
you think of a better creation than this
is it in anybody's imagination to think
anything better than what is there right
now
so as a Creator he has done his job
wonderfully well
but if you want life to happen the way
you want it because right now the very
Crux of your happiness and your
well-being is this
if at all if you're unhappy
the only and only reason why you're
unhappy is life is not happening the way
you think it should happen
that's all it is
so if life is not happening the way you
think it is it should happen you're
unhappy if life happens the way you
think it should happen you are happy
it's as simple as that
so if life has to happen the way you
think it should happen first of all
how you think
with how much Focus you think how much
stability is there in your thought and
how much reverberance is there in the
thought process will determine whether
your thought will become a reality or is
it just an empty thought
or
how you do not create any impediments
for your thought by creating negative
thought process
this possible is something possible or
not possible is destroying Humanity
what is possible and not possible is not
your business it's Nature's business
your business is just to strive but what
you want
[Music]
yo I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing roles from Rhonda Byrne
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there when you discover
who you are then everything else is
going to fall into place nothing's going
to be like I feel for sure that this was
my life purpose that discovering the
sacred and doing everything that I'm
doing I know for sure this is what I was
meant to do